so
the kind of experiences that I wish to
share
with my friends and my beloved our
experiences of window dressing our lived
experience
literally window dressing literally
giving
rise to
our inner life
the the invitation is into stewardship
of internal life so we wake up in the
morning and we say how about a bike ride
how about portaling into the Timeless
how about cruising through the landscape
with the Romantic abandon of a summer
day how about the feeling of a great
movie how about a pop song you always
loved because we tend to live in the
trappings of the mundane the boring and
the ordinary we're like permanently
booted out of the promised land the
Garden of Eden is a world within the
world that we seem to have lost access
to
you know we're told this by so many
Mystics and those in the know
he said the other world
it's this world rightly seen but how do
we
rightly see this world how do we awaken
the mind's attention from the lethargy
of custom and the film of familiarity
and redirected towards the wonders of
existence how do we bring ourselves into
this feeling how do we soar across the
landscape how do we boot up these new
semiotic Universe how do we enter these
flow States how do we enter these
reveries how do we dance like no one's
watching how do we
cast Starlight upon ourselves and move
into the light how do we wake ourselves
up
you know listen to this song
listen to what it feels like listening
to the instrumentation and the guitar
and the immersive power it casts upon
you look at what this melody does look
at what it says look at what it suggests
look at what it emotes look up at the
Sun and notice notice the way this song
transports you hurls you into a place
of captivation and immersion you are
engaged and the world has been brought
back into Focus
and finally
you're like holy moly every passing
minute becomes the best day of your life
all over again
[Laughter]
[Music]